[Musica]
se parliamo di second chance
dobbiamo prendere in considerazione due
aspetti il primo è ciò che ci impedisce
di realizzare i nostri sogni
sapete cos'è è il talento sì lo so mi
state guardando come se fossi impazzito
ma lasciate che me lo spieghi con un
esempio io ho un grandissimo amico che è
un giornalista della rai dalla coda
quando è nato ha sempre avuto il sogno
di lavorare e vivere negli stati uniti
d'america
io lo conosco da otto anni da quando ho
iniziato questa avventura negli stati
uniti e ogni anno ogni volta che
parliamo
gli propongo sempre qualcosa che gli
poste lo possa aiutare a realizzare il
suo sogno è la sua risposta è sempre la
stessa è stefano ma io so fare solo il
giornalista
e la mia risposta ilaria correzione e
puntualmente la stessa
no caro dario tu non sai fare solo il
giornalista
tu hai dimostrato di saper fare persino
il giornalista
sì perché in realtà spesso non riusciamo
a cogliere le opportunità ea realizzare
dei progetti perché ci siamo costruiti
attorno una gabbia le cui sbarre sono i
talenti e ciò in cui siamo stati bravi
fino ad oggi cioè ciò che ci ha reso
qualcuno in un settore perché ancora ci
portiamo dietro il retaggio delle
generazioni precedenti dove per tutta la
vita si faceva lo stesso lavoro si
entrava dal posto più umile di
un'impresa poi con il tempo con
l'anzianità si cresceva che si arrivava
il fatidico giorno della pensione come
fantozzi quando si usciva e c'era la
grande festa 40 anni 30 anni 50 anni
nella stessa impresa facendo lo stesso
lavoro nella stessa nello stesso ufficio
oggi non è più così questa etichetta non
c'è
piacere stefano versace broker
assicurativo piacere dario celli
giornalista rai piacere mario rossi
falegname oggi non si usa più
non si dice più perché in agli stati
uniti se il tu lavori per oltre cinque
anni nella stessa impresa facendo le
stesse cose per di valore verdi valore
perché automaticamente hai dimostrato di
non saper essere brutti le di non
sapersi adattare a un mondo che cambia
sempre più freneticamente
sappiamo tutti che il mondo è cambiato
negli ultimi 50 anni più di quanto abbia
fatto nei 500 precedenti e negli ultimi
5 più di quanto abbia fatto negli ultimi
50 quindi non si può rimanere chiusi
dentro questa gabbia per pensando che
sia la unica cosa che sappiamo fare
io vengo dal mondo delle assicurazioni
mi ricordo che a 16 anni prendevo la mia
moto scivola al liceo scientifico e
lunedì mercoledì e venerdì andavo da
ancona falconara marittima
ad aprire la mia sub agenzia di
assicurazioni ho iniziato così facendo
piccole polis e vendendo polizze auto
polizze vita police e infortuni poi sono
cresciuto ho imparato nuovi nuovi
aspetti di questo lavoro fino a
diventare un esperto e broker
assicurativo di enti pubblici al punto
tale che il più grande broker al mondo
mi disse per favore vieni a lavorare da
noi perché sei diventato un incubo ci
troviamo ad ogni gara pubblica
e così fu io iniziai a lavorare con loro
poi sono andato né in venezuela dove per
cinque anni mi sono dedicato a una
compagnia di assicurazioni diventando il
loro dirigente in più importante nel
mondo delle riassicurazioni il mio mondo
per 16 anni che è stato quello delle
assicurazioni piacere stefano versaci
broker assicurativo poi ho deciso che
era il momento di cambiare
ho deciso che quei talenti che abbiamo
dimostrato in questo mondo mi potevo
utilizzare in un altro e così ho aperto
un piccolo ristorante urbino da lì è
iniziata la mia avventura nel mondo del
food un mondo completamente
verso del quale non sapevo nulla ma ero
cosciente che avevo dei talenti che
avrebbero dato i risultati anche in un
altro settore
da lì sono evoluto abbiamo deciso con la
mia famiglia di realizzare il sogno di
vivere negli stati uniti d'america e
siamo venuti ad aprire la nostra prima
gelateria
oggi siamo leader del mondo del gelato
qui in florida e negli stati uniti
d'america grazie al fatto che non ci
siano creati questa gabbia
quindi il primo augurio che vi faccio e
di rompere le sbarre di questa gabbia
che vi siete costruiti da solo
inevitabilmente che è costituita dai
vostri talenti da quello che sapete fare
da quello che vi credete di essere bravi
a fare e che sia la unica cosa che
sapete fare
no avete dei talenti li potete
utilizzare in qualsiasi settore
la seconda parte che bisogna affrontare
quando si parla di second chance è il
rapporto che si ha con il fallimento
pessimo per gli italiani davvero pessimo
pensate titoloni dei giornali
imprenditore si suicida per il
fallimento della sua impresa
innanzitutto l'imprenditore non si
suicida per il fallimento della sua
impresa ma si suicida per il pessimo
rapporto che ha con il fallimento perché
gli imprenditori falliscono anche negli
stati uniti eppure gli stati uniti un
titolo del genere non lo vedrai mai non
vedrai mai un imprenditore che si
suicida perché la sua impresa è fallita
sapete perché perché negli stati uniti
fallire
e normale e socialmente accettato sin
dai tempi della scuola
io adoro la scuola dei miei figli una
scuola pubblica dove appena entri c'è un
poster gigante con scritto make mistake
cioè fi errori sotto c'è scritto la
penicillina è stata scoperta per errore
i nostri programmi sono studiati per far
sperimentare i nostri ragazzi e
abituarli all'errore
perché questo è ciò che li aspetta nella
vita se ci pensi anche nella scuola
italiana
c'era quando andavo io a scuola quella
famosa matita i due colori il rosso da
una parte che indicava il cuore
errore è normale e poi quando la roma
era gravissimo
allora c'era l'errore marcato col blu ok
si penalizza si castiga chi sbaglia
negli stati uniti non si castiga chi
sbaglia perché se vai a scuole perché
devi imparare normale che sbagli si
premia chi ce la fa e questo non aver
castigo sin da bambini ti permette di
cominciare a vivere l'esperienza della
vita senza aver paura del fallimento
ora c'è una frase che io adoro
tantissimo negli stati uniti che si
richiama che dice fail first cioè
fallisci rapido fallisci velocemente
perché prima fallisci prima raggiunge
l'obiettivo
prendiamo la mia storia io nele negli
otto anni che ho creato qui la catena di
gelateria più grande degli stati uniti
avrò chiuso almeno una dozzina di
gelateria ma senza chiusura di quelle
dodici gelaterie che o meno
oggi non avrei una ventina di gelateria
prestigiose nei migliori angoli di miami
possiamo considerare quelle dodici
gelaterie un fallimento o un passaggio
obbligato se ci pensi al fallito dal
primo giorno che sei nato è fallito
quando ha iniziato a provare a camminare
hai fallito quando ha iniziato a parlare
hai fallito quando ha iniziato a
studiare matematica è il fallito quando
hai studia ha cominciato ad andare in
bicicletta per oggi sai parlare
sai camminare se andare in bicicletta
due conti li sa pride anche fare e
questo perché sei passato per quei
fallimenti senza paura senza problemi
capendo facendo tuo sin da bambino che
il bayern era normale
ecco quindi quel film fest che dicono
negli stati uniti significa non aver
paura comincia subito a fallire comincia
subito non aspettare il momento perfetto
procrastinare è dovuto al fatto che
abbiamo sbagliato
avevamo paura di sbagliare aspettiamo il
momento giusto per fare le cose
il momento giusto non esiste il momento
perfetto non esiste la perfezione è
qualcosa che uccide l'imprenditoria
uccide la vita delle persone
bisogna fare tentativi bisogna provare
bisogna sbagliare bisogna correggere
perché solo correggendo gli errori si
raggiunge il successo quindi il mio più
grande augurio che posso farti a te che
stai vedendo questo intervento è quello
di prendere la valigia di metterci
dentro tutto ciò che è sempre sognato di
realizzare di metterci dentro i tuoi
sogni
i tuoi obiettivi i tuoi desideri
metterli dentro e uscire fuori uscire
fuori e cominciare a fallire
ti auguro di fallire il più presto
possibile perché il successo è quel
premio straordinario che si trova dietro
l'angolo dove hai commesso
l'ultimo errore